[Música]
bien
rafael landívar
es un guatemalteco nacido en 1700 él es
uno de los poetas
neorrenacentistas más respetados de
américa
unos años antes de morir en el exilio él
escribió un poema dedicado a guatemala
en el hace menciones de ricos bosques de
campos siempre verdes
y por primera vez documenta el término
de eterna primavera asociado a esta
región
es interesante ver
que muchos años después todavía en el
imaginario guatemalteco existe el tema
de eterna primavera nos consideramos
miembros de este país de la eterna
primavera
mucho tiempo antes escrito en quiché
antiguo el libro sagrado de los mayas el
popol vuh inicia con estas cinco
palabras para el quiche uvi que
significa en un lugar llamado tierra de
muchos árboles
durante la conquista los españoles
llamaron a este sitio guatemala que
significa tierra de bosques
el reconocido científico ruso
babylon
determinó que mesoamérica era uno de los
sitios origen de especies cultivadas más
importantes del planeta
esto es un indicador de como una cultura
ancestral vinculada a ecosistemas
altamente biodiversos fue capaz de
extraer recursos fitogenéticos
domesticarlos
y producir plantas útiles para la
humanidad
entre estas plantas destacan el maíz el
chocolate calabazas el bleu
hace pocos años guatemala
fue reconocida como un país megadiverso
este es un reconocimiento que muy pocos
países tienen en la tierra
veamos en dónde está esa eterna
primavera
qué es lo que ha pasado con nuestros
bosques
hemos sido capaces como sociedad
de revertir los valores de cobertura de
bosques en este país en tan sólo 60 años
hemos ido de tener un 75 por ciento de
cobertura a un 30 por ciento en el 2010
incluso somos uno de los países con la
deforestación más alta sostenida de la
tierra
esto no tiene otro nombre más que un
desastre ecológico y social
el papá francisco
en su encíclica law datos y
tras reconocer
la raíz humana en esta grave
problemática de la humanidad propone la
transición hacia un nuevo modelo de
convivencia social basado en la ecología
en el cuidado de la casa común y en la
atención a los pobres
como iniciar esta transición hay un
acuerdo entre científicos filósofos y
políticos que son tres los pasos
principales
en primer lugar un conocimiento profundo
y objetivo de la realidad
a partir de eso generar una
transformación en la conciencia de las
personas
y finalmente llevar
a acciones transformadoras de la
realidad
el primer paso es limpiar la mesa el
conocimiento de la verdad el
conocimiento profundo de la realidad
merece
evadir los mitos
evadir prejuicios con poco fundamento
en guatemala la primavera no es eterna
esta afirmación se apoya en la grave
crisis ambiental que enfrentamos
además en el cambio climático es
importante mencionar que centroamérica
es una de las regiones que más cambios
ha sufrido y puede sufrir relacionado
con el cambio climático
la naturaleza tiene límites los recursos
que la naturaleza nos ofrece no son
inagotables aparentemente esto es algo
que no es completamente comprendido por
los tomadores de decisiones y por la
sociedad en general
pues bien la ciencia nos da algunos
métodos para comprender nuestra realidad
uno de ellos es el sistema socio
ecológico
el cual se define como un sistema
complejo pero complejo no es equivalente
a complicado simplemente hace referencia
a que está compuesto por varios
componentes que interaccionan entre sí
el sistema socio ecológico se basa en la
naturaleza
la cual proporciona bienes
servicios y recursos a la sociedad ya la
economía los cuales a su vez
generan impactos positivos o negativos
en la naturaleza
teóricamente el sistema institucional es
el llamado a guardar el equilibrio en
este sistema socio ecológico
sabiendo esto vayamos a la región
metropolitana para comprender un poco
más cuál es nuestra realidad
nosotros estamos ubicados en el punto
marino que ustedes ven
esta área metropolitana está definida en
términos hidrológicos tenemos como
límites en el oeste a la sierra de la
luz el otro límite montañoso en el este
es la montaña de pinula y en el centro
tenemos un valle central
que tiene una extensión aproximada de
norte a sur de 40 km
terminando con el lago de amatitlán en
el sur
hagamos un viaje
de lo aparente a lo oculto
empecemos haciendo un análisis de la
cobertura forestal en tan solo 25 años
la mitad de los bosques existentes en
1990 desapareció
vamos un poco más profundo
es necesario para entender la
interacción entre la sociedad y la
naturaleza el conocimiento adecuado de
los recursos hídricos del agua sin
embargo el estudio de este recurso es
complicado porque continuamente está en
movimiento y porque algunas veces se
deposita en sitios difíciles de tener
acceso
pero la ciencia vuelve a ayudarnos y te
contamos con el método de isótopos
comencemos desagregando la molécula de
agua
los elementos que la constituyen
aquí tenemos
un átomo de hidrógeno el cual es el
elemento más simple en la naturaleza
tiene un protón en su núcleo y tiene un
electrón dando vueltas
los isótopos son átomos del mismo
elemento
pero tienen una diferencia tienen un
neutrón adicional en el núcleo
esto nos da
las características que químicamente son
iguales los isótopos es decir pueden
reaccionar como el hidrógeno y
eventualmente reaccionan como el agua
sin embargo tienen una diferencia son
físicamente diferentes es decir tienen
un mayor peso esta es una ventaja para
trazar
el sic en el agua en el ciclo
hidrológico todos sabemos que las
lluvias en guatemala provienen de la
evaporación del mar
con el método de isótopos es
identificable es tratable el recorrido
del agua porque la concentración de
estos isótopos pesados disminuye
progresivamente en cuanto se alejan del
mar o ascienden las montañas es nuestro
papel buscar en la naturaleza las
concentraciones isotópicas que nosotros
podemos encontrar en la lluvia en los
ríos o en los pozos
para estudiarlos el agua subterránea
el instituto de ciencia y tecnología de
la universidad rafael landívar se tomó
la tarea de definir cuáles son las
principales áreas de recarga hídrica en
la región metropolitana para eso
llevamos a cabo un muestreo de agua de
isótopos de lluvia
en los ríos y en el agua subterránea a
través de los pozos
el primer hallazgo que tuvimos estuvo
muy bien
definimos cuáles son las principales
áreas de recarga hídrica vinculadas a la
lluvia y a las montañas que nos rodean
estos son los sitios de mayor recarga
porque es donde más llueve y porque la
cobertura forestal es adecuada
sin embargo
cuando empezamos a hacer el modelo
hidrogeológico o más simplemente es
decir empezamos a estudiar el recorrido
del agua subterránea empezamos a
evidenciar los problemas
podemos ver en la parte del valle
central una alta densidad de pozos esta
alta densidad de pozos no tiene conexión
con las áreas de recarga hídrica
ubicadas en las partes altas de montaña
la lluvia de las partes altas de montaña
recarga los pozos de poblados como san
lucas y como mismo
pero no alimenta al donde más extracción
hay esto nos ha llevado a datos
alarmantes por ejemplo hay sitios en
donde se reportan más de 10 metros de
disminución del nivel freático
esto significa 400 metros en 40 años
por otro lado se ha documentado que
existen más de 1500 pozos en este valle
central sin control
de la extracción que se puede llevar a
cabo
el nivel entre extracción y recarga
hídrica natural es de 5 a 1 es decir
nosotros extraemos 5 veces más que lo
que la naturaleza puede recargar en un
año hidrológico
otro hallazgo importante es que los ríos
han cambiado su comportamiento
pasaron de ser ríos efluentes esto
significa que el acuífero es el que
proporciona agua a los ríos a ser ríos
influentes es decir los ríos
proporcionan agua al acuífero y esto es
alarmante porque actualmente lo que
estos ríos son
todos lo sabemos es
desagües de aguas servidas
podemos hacer
muy bonitos esquemas pero quisiera que
dejáramos a la realidad hablar por sí
misma
y no quiero confundirlos soy optimista
soy optimista porque sé que esta verdad
nos hará reaccionar para tomar nuevas
medidas y borrar esto de nuestro país
esto ocurre apenas a 6 kilómetros de
este lugar
cuál es la proyección
degradación ambiental deforestación
aumento de la población humana
probablemente en 2032 seamos más de 3.5
millones de habitantes únicamente en el
municipio de guatemala
esta visión
es para mostrar
que lo que nosotros vemos como evidente
en el lago de amatitlán que se ha
convertido en una fosa séptica y
depósito de basura desde el punto de
vista químico es exactamente lo que le
está pasando al acuífero de la ciudad de
guatemala de donde nos abastecemos más
de 4 millones de personas
solo lleva un poco más de tiempo
pero el colapso de este acuífero está
próximo probablemente en 10 años
tengamos algún evento importante
que haga colapsar nuestro sistema
pero soy optimista
quiero que eso no pase
en conclusión llegamos a evidenciar que
en muy corto tiempo pasamos de ser un
sistema socio ecológico estable
a un sistema socio ecológico al borde
del colapso
basado
en la crisis del ciclo hidrológico en la
región metropolitana
solo necesitamos
un golpe
un terremoto
una crisis social o simplemente tiempo
para que esta región sea inviable
no quiero confundirlos soy optimista
quiero que mis hijos no den la misma
charla que yo estoy dando
y quiero mencionarles el desastre
ecológico que estamos enfrentando ya hay
personas que viven en él
sin acceso ao
escasez o abundancia
es una decisión
la escasez
en el corto plazo a escala masiva
es muy fácil simplemente sigamos
haciendo lo que hasta el momento hemos
estado haciendo sin embargo la
restauración de la cuenca del lago de
amatitlán la restauración de la cuenca
del río las vacas es posible
el acuífero
los ríos los bosques
están a nuestro alcance restaurarlos
sin embargo debemos de tomar decisiones
integrales y profundas
en cuanto al sistema ambiental
necesitamos detener la deforestación
y recuperar áreas de recarga hídrica
reciclaje de agua
inyección al acuífero de agua limpia
pero sobre todo y de forma definitiva
eliminar
el desecho de tóxicos a nuestras cuencas
en nuestros ríos ese es el primer paso
en cuanto al subsistema social y
económico
debemos pedir más
y dar más
es importante que nos convirtamos en los
gestores de nuestra propia seguridad
hídrica
es crítico empezar
con el mejoramiento de prácticas de uso
y desecho de los recursos hídricos no
más desechos tóxicos en nuestros ríos
el sistema institucional debe asumir su
rol de líder y de legitimidad para
conducir procesos de revertir el grave
deterioro de nuestro sistema ambiental
pero soy optimista
quiero que esta imagen nos conmueva a
todos para que hoy mismo empecemos a
marcar la diferencia
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]